pores Harbor
sombres recoins de violence et d'horreur
Je ne suis qu'un homme qui se cache dans le coin avec
la caméra qui regarde ce gars faire le réalisateur le plus
célèbre de l'histoire de construire
ce livre des psychos divertissent diaboliquement
des éléments graphiques de violence brutale
horrible Peggy c'est le garçon  qui a déterré
sa propre mère
qu'est-ce que l'arme je pense que c'est le couteau
qui un instant plus tard lui a coupé le cri
et sa tête la
charmante Doris Day devrait le faire comme une
comédie musicale votre film ne sortira pas
dans ce pays c'est mr.  Le
prochain film d'Hitchcock est-ce que tu es dedans ou tu
vas juste devoir aller charger ma chère comment
vas-tu tourner cette scène de douche
c'est seulement que bien à partir d'ici ce n'est pas
exactement un garçon tu ne devrais pas attendre à
mi-chemin tue-la après  30
minutes ben je fais une terrible
erreur
ça va être splendide mariée à un homme
obsédé par le meurtre
Denise tu peux me donner ton
soutien moral je suis ta femme et je supporte
ces gens qui me regardent comme si j'étais
étaient invisibles parce que tout ce qu'ils peuvent voir,
c'est le grand Alfred Hitchcock sans gloire,
j'ai promis à ma mère que je ne le dirais pas